don't get sucked into
people's
own agendas of what they need
you know you just make sure that you
serve
the product you serve the movie
always
i heard you say in another interview
that a common thing for a lot of
filmmakers actors screenwriters is that
they think their first film
is going to sort of set the trajectory
for the rest of their career like they
maybe they get a lot of praise they walk
the red carpet
people are you know emailing you and you
think that it's
up from there and that it's actually
very humbling to see that it's not yes i
do um
certainly i was humbled our crew was
humble our group um
you know the first one we did you know
had you know andy garcia in it you know
a whole bunch of people there's red
carpets there was
premieres there was all kinds of great
screenings and everything else
and you know you you kind of put you
know
weinsteins are calling you the agencies
are calling you
and you realize
that
we're not given in this
world and this universal film that we've
decided to be in
um there is no stability in it i mean
there's there's no the trajectory is uh
is what it becomes and you have to make
it
um it never goes to easy street
um and
we were doing a lot of things um you
know trying to thinking that we were
trying to get this bigger film made you
know it's just you're gonna do this one
the size and the next one's gonna be the
next size well it turned out the next
one was half the size and then the next
one half the size of that
so
that is my filmmaking journey it doesn't
go like that it's all over the place
and i realized that
um you know we can go back to
the original idea which is just to keep
working
and not let anything get in the way not
let all the needs to
set things up here and set things up
here and raise all this money let's find
a way to just keep
making films and add value
and so my trajectory
went through
you know
this kind of organic film school because
when i was with the first film i didn't
really
understand much about what was going on
there was a bunch of experts around me
that knew everything
and they said you know you're the big
boss and so you go over there and you
get an assistant and
do all this different stuff and it was
really cool but i didn't if i i didn't
know everything that was all the
the different machinations of what was
happening
and it cost us frankly
um if i would have known that now i'd
have been like wait a minute
you don't need that and this and that
you could just have that why are we
paying for all three but i didn't know
any better and so
so the the
you know
i you know i wouldn't change a thing you
know i learned so much now i can do
everything now i know
about all the different elements of the
film
business it's funny sometimes we do
production services you see directors
come in
and they don't know these things they
don't know
but you know
they just say i just want this
and
it's like oh okay but you don't need
that
but but i want it because they say we
want it and everything else
but
now i know what we want and need it i
can distill it down to what's on the
screen
because at the end of the day
if you want to
keep your budgets at the level that you
can keep working consistently
in independent film you have to
just worry about what's on that screen
because what's behind it may not it
might not always be
very pretty to watch the sausage being
made
but
as long as
we get what we want on the screen
then
that's what matters as long as we get
into the edit
and we can have everything we need
that's what
that's what counts
and so
um
you know we do sometimes smaller films
now we do a little bit larger films
and we can do them all and we're
comfortable at all budget levels
um
and
you know sometimes it's about the
expectations
that people have
and you know the optics you need to
create for a client
which is all money i tell them that too
i said if you let us do it and you're
not worried about it then we can do it
for less if you're there watching us you
know everything is going to be a little
more because it's our job to make sure
that the optics are are correct and you
have a certain type of experience that
you're expecting
and you said you had people maybe
well-meaning
in your ear saying it needs to be this
way
and so maybe more money was spent or
things were done in a different way how
much exposure to the industry did you
have growing up you said you lived in la
briefly or i did i had almost none
just especially not production
um i had been on
working for
a guy by name iran shuset for a while
who's the writer producer of alien total
recall minority report
and you know i was on the development
side with him and working with his
management to get some projects off the
ground but as far as onset production it
was just this huge mystery to me
um and
you know it feels glamorous you know
it's like you're on set and all these
things are going on and all these people
with the headphones and and they're
calling you sir and it's it's really
intoxicating
um but i but so but i had really no real
idea of what was
what was going on
um
you know other than the basic leadership
stuff okay i
make sure that everybody's paid and
things of that sort but
um
you know as far as uh
knowing that the intricate details of
production
i really didn't know much at all and and
and but you need to know
you need to know a lot because if people
will tell you you need this kind of
camera and you need these things with
the camera you and this and that and
this and that and you're
doing a shot that could be done on
sticks
with a doorway dolly
and you don't always need everything
they're talking about you need so in
order for you to be able to look at them
squint out and say
please don't tell me you need that
because i know we don't need it i know
exactly what we need and we can just do
it like that
so this is
part of that learning process you know
over
you know failure and
all the things that you
learn through a trial and error and
failure frankly
and so for a first film
a director producer may have to take it
a little bit and
nod their head and then maybe after what
third film
they can have that conversation
yeah uh first film um is you know you're
nervous half the time you know you just
it's a lot of pressure
to direct a film
and it's more pressure than i think
people
are
think it's gonna be i've seen it drive
people literally crazy and they just go
crazy and just start doing crazy things
and saying crazy things
and
i'll tell you um
you know
once you
get that through through that process
then you know you at least you know you
can get through it you know that you can
get through it emotionally
and
you know you learn a lot
from that
and
your second third projects
yeah then you can start to tell people
hey
i know what we need
i know what we need i know we don't need
that
and
you know you learn to listen to people
around you that you trust
and make sure that you
don't get sucked into
people's
um own agendas of what they need you
know you just make sure that you serve
the product you serve the movie
always
and you just keep that in mind
always serving the final product
you serve the final edit
more than you do
you know
getting all this
crazy outside coverage that you know
that you'll never need
you know so but that comes from
experience and it has to be a full
process meaning through the edit
because
the edit
editing
is the most important thing i've learned
is editing
because what that teaches you is what
you need and what you don't need
i don't know if you just watch a cut of
your film
six months after you shoot it you don't
know
how they made those decisions
to get to there if you sit there with
the editor
you know
okay we're going to go from here
geogra-create the geography of the room
we're going to get cut into coverage
and what is the point of the film we're
going to have to you know the shake
hands let's get that on an insert or a
special
and then you cut back out to the
geography
if you when you edit you learn that so
when you're in there filming
um
you know that that's what you need and
so you don't have to beat up your actors
with something on some shot list or
a lot of storyboards that maybe somebody
might have done for you you can just say
i got it and
a lot of people will thank you for that
you know
is there a way to handle agendas with
finesse
yeah well i i personally have a very
calm um
directing style and producing style i
don't get
banana shape
but
you try to listen to what they
are saying
and
you listen to it and then you have to
just say well i just we don't need that
or we do need it
if they have an agenda meaning
if they're thinking hey this is going to
be a shot for my reel
as a dp or something
i want the shot for your reel too if we
can afford it and if we have time and if
it makes sense other than that we're
going to have a shot for the end cut of
the movie
and
and so you just have to be firm
but if people look at you
and you're talking to them they'll know
if you know what you're talking about or
not
it's very hard to look at somebody and
say hey you know i know that we need
this
and that and that and this or this shot
and this and that and i look at him and
say no we don't we don't need it and
we've got everything we need on the
scene i know you want the big boom up
dolly down
cross over push in i get i want that too
but um we got to move on so
so you just be kind about it
um you know
i don't yell or anything like that but
you know you must assert your authority
um
on a set because there's too much going
on to not have a clear line of authority
and so i make sure that
i do that with kindness but with
but i'm relatively firm about it do you
think the agendas are stronger in los
angeles or in mexico or they're
different agendas
you know this is an opinion
very much stronger in los angeles
um you know
when you have american crew i've had
i've done scenes here
days of filming here it's a very very
different thing
you get people
that are very much concerned about
how they're going to
look be perceived
be blamed
things of that sort
and
they'll you'll hear a lot in the states
of hey this is gonna have my name on it
so it's gotta i don't feel comfortable
with this
uh
my name's on there as the gaffer so i
need to make sure that the lighting's
right
i don't find that in mexico at all
and i've worked with a few crews there
um
they
it's just the work ethic is a little bit
different um
they defer to the
to the director
i think a little bit more but then look
if you're going to build a career in la
you've got to get a real you got to get
a bunch of different stuff going on and
it's important
um you know you you have to keep your
the quality of your work a certain level
and you have to keep your reputation as
somebody easy to work with at a certain
level
um and that your work is done well you
can't
well you know that gaffer uh
completely messed up the lighting then
you may never work again or it might be
difficult to work again so so there's a
lot more pressures i don't blame them
for it
it's but it's but it's different and
and um
you know
i do
when you're a gaffer or whatever has
their own website
you know in their own real
uh you know that's like okay
that's but you know that shows that look
that's what they're kind of supposed to
do
they're supposed to get themselves out
there but
you know
when you're talking about because
all this is fixed with a lot of money if
you have a huge budget then you can have
those people but when you're when you
know that you're going to be in the
trenches of an indie you know it's going
to get sticky
you know that everything's not going to
go perfect
then you have to
loyalty and
loyalty to the project and the product
has to take precedent
i have a saying
and that's that
i always protect the film over
protecting myself
i protect the project
that means i gotta take
a lot of crap sometimes
a lot of abuse
but it has to always
what i'm doing has to always serve the
final product
and if i have to take
a little bit of someone yelling at me
whatever the case is then i'll take it
um
i find that sometimes in la
uh there's a lot of fighting and
bickering sometimes i'm not saying all
the time but sometimes and they just
you know people are upset and disguise
yelling at this guy and this guy and
this that but another reason i think
that is is because
a lot of times you'll go on to a set and
the gaffer will never have work with the
grip and the sound boom guy never worked
with the sound mixer it's like everybody
comes in for like
and then gets used to each other in
mexico our crew is set we work together
all the time so we it's like a shorthand
so um
so we know everybody's temperament and
you you learn to weed out people that
don't have
the correct temperament for what we're
trying to do
so
once you do your
tenth film or so you know
where you're where your where your weak
points are
and um and then you know your strong
points are so you say you always have
you always have the ability to do the
film
with just a very small core group
um and so
and that protects the film you know you
let you know in certain films maybe in
the states
one or two people go it's like
the film can't be done that day you know
what i'm saying we
we can
switch out loot positions and places and
parts so it all makes sense so um
yeah i mean at the end of the day uh
it's much different in my opinion much
different from
um los angeles to mexico but it's just
different it doesn't mean it's better or
worse it's just different so
um but for the money
that we try to put everything on the
screen so we just try to keep it as
streamlined as possible